as Aerys Targaryen x' behavior grew more
and more erratic the task of ruling the
Seven Kingdoms fell to me Tywin
Lannister I had served Aerys for nearly
20 years and as a result the realm had
prospered the Royal coffers were full
the land was at peace but Aerys grew
increasingly hostile jealous of the
success many credited to me my power and
influence unnerved him a captain of my
personal guard sir Ellen Payne was once
overheard making offhand comments
regarding who was the true ruler of
Westeros when the King was given this
information he had a limp Eanes tongue
ripped out with hot pincers it was my
desire to unite the houses of Lannister
and Targaryen through marriage my
daughter Cersei would marry Aerys eldest
son Prince Rhaegar such a union made
perfect sense for all parties however
Aerys senses had begun to leave him
quite some time earlier instead of
uniting the royal family with its most
loyal and powerful ally Aerys chose
instead to insult my family indicating
the sudden match was beneath Rhaegar
instead he chose Elia Martell of Dorne
to be Rhaegar wife as if to rub salt in
my wounds Aerys appointed Jaime my son
to the Kingsguard the Kingsguard may be
an honor for lesser families than ours
but it is a lifetime appointment that
forces him to renounce all family
Holdings this creates a difficulty in
naming an heir to Casterly Rock
but Ares knew all that I had grown tired
of the Kings constant provocation thus I
resigned my post as Ares hand and
returned to Casterly Rock with my
considerable forces when Robert
Baratheon rebelled against the throne
Aerys grew fearful that I would join
with Robert's forces and rise against
him in taught himself clever and kept
Jamie very close as if warning me he
sunk deeper and deeper into delusion
paranoia and violence I've heard it said
he became obsessed with wildfire a
substance which once lit cannot be
extinguished convinced he had enemies
all around him he wouldn't allow blades
in his presence save for those of his
Kingsguard alas that proved to be his
undoing